my theory on crop circles is quite
simply but it said because when you go
to these crops systems and actually see
what it's like to be there you see
here's what you see you see the crop
circles amazing you see a few ragtag
British freaks wandering around
scratching their heads and you see a
shitload of Japanese tourists well then
when you look at world media you see
that the Japanese media pays an
incredible amount of attention to these
things
and I think they are a covert operation
run by MIDI the Ministry of Trade and
Industry quite obviously this is an
experiment in the semiotic sub brand
recognition and all over England there
are roving bands of Japanese tourists
who at the snap of an icon rush into the
fields and from a tradition of centuries
of ninja and snapping they produce these
things Johnny quick and then put their
nikons back on
I understand why MIDI would be behind us
but what's the benefit there studying
the Western mind and its relationship to
brands the symbols these are symbols is
what their own people say their
communications well they're a [ __ ]
brained form of communication because
they don't communicate anything for
God's I mean what kind of communication
is it that doesn't communicate so and a
number of people have behaved very oddly
around the crop circles I mean for
example the other thing you see when you
go to southern England is my god their
RAF bases everywhere and nuclear weapons
bunkers and cruise missiles and this and
that and you're asked to believe that
the Ministry of Defence is utterly
sanguine about the fact that the
airspace of England is being violated
night after night by a mysterious agency
that is if you can snap the stem of a
weak stock you can throw the switch on a
machine you
the Ministry of Defense would go crazy
if this was real
one theory Rupert and I came up with
this it's called the out on a limb
theory which is it is possible that
inside mi5 which is british intelligence
there is a certain amount of concern
about the growth of New Age ideas in
England
and so the idea is to lure these people
out on to a limb wilder and Wilder
statements about dyin messages and the
telluric forces of the earth and so
forth and so on
and then once every not in England has
signed on to this phenomenon you just
hold a demonstration bring on your
you know jumpsuit a team of crop circle
makers and say we mi5 we did it and you
people should now all find honest word
because your level of credibility is now
exposed is basically close to zero but I
like the Japanese action and I think the
cattle mutilations of a few years ago in
the states were as though a Japanese
project I mean it had all the Japanese
and American elements you know the
lonely American Prairie with it's
brooding sense of strongmen
King evil and then you know the Japanese
love of animal mutilation shiny blades
mysterious padding around I mean
it's
that might be a good test of the
starwars system and the guys are having
fun with the joystick people have
suggested that although again you would
think that wheat fields of Western
Siberia would be doing it at Glastonbury
he doesn't I mean they wouldn't get any
status and recognition that way I mean
they they blasted anyone get some
recognition from the human mind is
incredibly perverse I know he's like
have one real mysteries can take
enormous pressure
[Music]